hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe i'm your host sean
carroll
today we're on idea number 22 which is
cosmology
now when i say that you might have some
conflicting reactions on the one hand
of course i was going to talk about
cosmology at some point it's an
important part
of our understanding of the physical
universe it's something that i'm
supposed to know
something about on the other hand does
it really count as an idea
so much as a subject matter or field of
study right
but i think it does count as an idea
because the real idea i want to get at
is
the fact that we can know so much about
the universe that we can
model the universe in a very very simple
way you know we could imagine universes
that were much harder to get to
intellectually they were much harder to
get a grasp of but our universe is
actually something we can know a lot
about
it's the ultimate spherical cow we can
make very nice
assumptions that make us go very far
that's the idea that i think
is worth thinking about so the idea
in other words the sort of in slightly
more technical terms the idea is
that the universe is more or less the
same everywhere
more or less uniform
okay so there are technical ways of
talking about this and so
let me put make this specific the
universe capital u's universe is more or
less uniform
now there was this long-standing uh
sort of tradition of elevating this into
a principle
okay this was called the cosmological
principle that
if you averaged over local uh
differences from place to place on very
large scales
the universe was two things number one
it was homogeneous
in space so it's the same at every
location
but also it was isotropic so if you
looked around in different directions at
every location you see the same kind of
thing
and this was developed into the
cosmological principle that the universe
was uniform and the same everywhere
i don't think it should be a principle i
mean maybe it's
a principle is something that you think
you know has to be right right you know
it
from the principle flow other things the
uniformity of the universe i take it at
this point in the history of cosmology
is just an empirical fact we just
observe the universe and it is that way
it didn't have to be that way right
we're so used to it by now that we sort
of think of it as automatic but
you could imagine what you used to be
called the island universe hypothesis
that you know something like the milky
way galaxy
was all by itself in otherwise empty
universe in a lot of ways
in many many ways that would have been a
simpler universe if there'd just been
one
collection of stuff otherwise in an
empty void that would have made a lot
more sense
more speculatively you could have
imagined universes where
conditions were just wildly different
from place to place i mean maybe the
density
of stars or something like that or even
the laws of physics could be wildly
different from place to place
now these days cosmologists do imagine
such a thing but they put
the regions where things could be very
very different outside of our observable
universe
so really today in this biggest idea of
video we're sticking to the observable
universe where things look more or less
the same
everywhere now you know footnote
not exactly the same everywhere things
are not the same here on earth as they
are in the desolate cold of interstellar
space
so we're doing some averaging we're
mentioning that statistically on
sufficiently large scales
things look more and more uniform
everywhere and you can go to
you know when i was a graduate student
you know late 80s early 90s
there were still people who thought that
the universe was sort of fractal
on large scales it was kind of lumpy in
some places
very very under dense in other regions
again
our data has improved and that idea has
fallen out of favor
if you average over bigger and bigger
regions our universe looks
uniform that's an empirical fact so how
do we get there
um it was hubble edwin hubble
in the 1920s he had helped and another
you know another footnote here is that
hubble worked with a lot of other people
schleifer and humison and so forth um
and he used ideas from a lot of other
people
like lemetra um but he gets and deserves
a lot of credit for doing what he did so
this is not a history lesson
by all means check out the history it's
fascinating and important
you know that what one of the things
hubble discovered was the universe is
expanding but before that
he found out that the universe was big
okay
that spiral nebulae
these things you see in the sky uh if
you're an astronomer
these sort of fuzzy patches there's a
whole bunch of fuzzy patches in the sky
uh all called nebulae and they didn't
know what they were in the early days
and what hubble figured out is that some
of them with these
pretty spiral shapes
are distinct galaxies
just like the milky way so before that
it was perfectly plausible to believe
and many people did believe that
we did live in an island universe okay
there were a bunch of nebulae but they
were just clouds of gas and dust
within our galaxy and it was really
hubble that showed that some of these
clouds of gas and dust were very far
away
and given their size and their
brightness they had to be separate
galaxies all by themselves
and then that's what really let people
believe in a respectable way that maybe
the universe was uniform hubble didn't
prove that by any means
but he sort of let you believe it um how
could he do that there was a
breakthrough by henrietta levitt
even earlier 1912 i think
which was the period luminosity relation
for cepheid variable stars
i'm just going to write period
luminosity relation
sometimes known as levitz law now
and what this is there's a certain kind
of star cepheid variables
and again there's footnotes here too
because astronomy is a god-awful mess if
you get into the details of stars and
galaxies so there's different kinds of
cepheid variables they didn't know about
that at the time
but what levitt discovered was that
there was
uh these variable stars are
pulsating okay they get bigger and they
get smaller they get bigger and their
brightness goes along with them
what she discovered was that uh there
was a relationship you know
it was known that different stars had
different periods different
vibrational periods and what she was
able to do was to use parallax
to figure out the the distance to some
nearby cepheid variables
and she saw that their luminosity their
brightness
was correlated with their periods and
the reason why this is crucially
important is because you know i
mentioned parallax so parallax is just
the idea
if here we are here's the sun and here's
the earth going around it
okay so you're here on earth and you're
looking out at some star
over here and there are even further
away stars over here
when you're looking at the star here
at one time of the year you will see it
in this background and then at the
six months later you're going to see it
behind a slightly different background
so
far away stars remain fixed nearby stars
seem to move a little bit just like you
know things seem to move if you just
move your head
a little bit okay that's parallax it
only it works as a way of measuring the
distance the parallax is bigger the
closer the star is
so it only works when the stars are
pretty darn close
right if they're very very far away then
you can't measure the parallax at least
you couldn't in 1912. now
if you listen to my podcast we talked to
lena nasib
who talked about this gaia
satellite project that we have now that
can measure the parallax to a billion
stars and you're figuring out where
every star
is in the milky way and that's great but
back in the day you could only do this
for very very
nearby stars so for these nearby stars
you find this relationship
so what that means is that you could you
measure
nearby stars using parallax you find
that some of them have this period
luminosity relation
and then if you find similar stars with
the same period
far away you know how bright they are
and therefore you know how far away they
are
this is the fundamental challenge for
observational cosmology is figuring out
how far away things are if you walk out
in a dark night
and see stars in the sky they all look
like you know bright spots in the sky
they don't look any different from each
other some are brighter
some are dimmer if we lived in a
wonderful world where every star had the
same intrinsic brightness
you'd instantly know how far away they
are those will be called
standard candles standard candles are
things where you know
precisely how bright they are
intrinsically therefore how bright they
appear to be tells you how far away they
are stars are not standard candles real
stars have intrinsic
low luminosity high luminosity etc
levitt showed that for these specific
cepheid variables you could figure out
what their intrinsic luminosity was
by measuring their period what hubble
was able to do
was to locate you know he and his
collaborators located cepheid variable
stars
in other galaxies stars inside
spiral nebulae and what they found was
that the they were so dim
when you observe them they must be super
duper far away which corresponds to
being separate galaxies all by
themselves okay
so then you know that was what i said
like i said this means that we do not
live in an island universe there's a
bunch of galaxies
scattered throughout the cosmos by
itself they didn't have nearly good
enough data
to show that they were uniformly
scattered but it's a natural
assumption and that's what people
started assuming i mean people had
guessed that
already even before um okay so what
would the world be like
what happens to a universe
in a universe with uniform density
well this would be a really good and
difficult
problem if isaac newton had been correct
about gravity right i mean newton said
that space and time were fixed
things are pulling on each other so we
already talked about this puzzle before
if you just scattered galaxies or
stars or whatever uniformly
through space they're all pulling on
each other so
do they all cancel out or somehow does
everything move
in toward each other that's a puzzle in
newtonian gravity
but by the time we were asking this
question observationally we had general
relativity right einstein had come along
and it's no longer a puzzle there's a
very clear answer
the answer is a universe like this
should either be expanding
or contracting it can't be standing
still
so there is something called that's the
well
you can talk about the relative size of
the universe
and that will either be increasing or
decreasing over time
if it's just stuck there it will start
decreasing okay
now einstein was the first to figure
this out around 1917 very soon you know
kind of remarkably soon after he
invented general relativity
he plugged his theory into this and he
realized you cannot have a static
space-time with uniform matter all
through it
so this bothered him so you're thinking
1917 that's before
hubble had discovered that there were
spiral galaxies so
there's i think i already mentioned this
in another video but there is uh
this uh story that is incorrect that
goes around
says that einstein was philosophically
wedded to the idea of a static universe
but that's not true he wasn't
philosophically wedded to it he
asked the astronomers what is the
universe is it static or is it expanding
or contracting
in 1917 they said well it's static we
don't see any any evidence that the
universe is expanding or contracting
so what einstein did is said well that
that sounds like
so what he could have done was be super
bold
right he could have said look it's 1917.
observational cosmology has not advanced
that far
i'm going to disbelieve my experimental
friends who say that the universe is
static and i'm going to make a
prediction that once cosmology gets to
be
more advanced we will realize that
either the universe is expanding or it's
contracting
that is not actually what he did what he
did was he believed his observational
friends and he said look
um i need to change my theory my theory
general relativity
seems to be in conflict with the data so
i'm going to try to fix it this is a
very respectable scientific thing to do
it's not you know
it has nothing to do with being
hamstrung by an incorrect
philosophical orientation so what he
said was you know we have einstein's
equation
and this is the equation that he used to
derive the fact that the universe must
either be expanding or contracting
r mu nu minus one half r
g mu nu equals eight
pi g i'm not gonna i'm gonna write a
room here right
[Music]
8 pi g t mu
so we talked about this equation before
when we talked about gravity
don't didn't go into all the details but
it's an equation between two different
four by four matrices on the left-hand
side the r mu minus one f r g minou
that's a way of characterizing the
curvature of space-time
the right-hand side eight by g t nu
that's the way characterizing the stuff
the energy the momentum the heat the
pressure
all that stuff that is causing space
time to curve and what einstein said is
look i'm allowed to
add a constant call it lambda the greek
letter lambda
times the metric tensor g mu nu to the
left hand side of my equation
and then i can actually what i find is
that if that value lambda which he
called the cosmological constant
if lambda is positive it pushes space
apart
if it's negative it pulls things
together so ordinary matter and
radiation
tends to pull together okay whereas
positive cosmological constant pushes
apart so he says i can pick a value of
lambda
that's exactly precisely right to
balance
the tendency of matter to pull toward
each other and have the universe
contract therefore i can make a static
universe and there's he even solved the
equations
uh this equation exactly and something
that we now call guess what
the einstein static universe okay sadly
for einstein um he missed a chance
because he should have
stuck by his guns uh well maybe we'll
we'll talk about the the subtleties here
in a second hubble
came along again and in 1927
the universe is expanding he never said
this by the way it's interesting
uh hubble hubble was actually you know
he was an
extraordinarily talented observational
cosmologist
he was not a theorist and he didn't
pretend to be a theorist and all this
gender relativity stuff was
you know he was hands off about that he
was non-judgmental
so what he found was the hubble law or
the hubble relation which
is that when you measure the distance to
a galaxy
you can also measure its apparent
velocity right this is something we can
do like like distances are hard to
measure
but doppler shifts are easy to measure
stars give off light
and in certain regimes they give off
very very well-known
frequencies of light or wavelengths of
light if the star is coming toward you
that light will be blue shifted if it's
moving away from you it's redshifted
so there's an apparent velocity that
stars and galaxies have
and those are easy to measure that's
what astronomers are good at and what
hubble found is that there is a
relationship
it was a mess in his original plot
velocity
versus distance but it's more or less a
straight line with a slope so
velocity is a certain constant which we
now call the hubble constant
h times the distance okay
so we can interpret that as saying that
the universe is expanding hub will never
use those words but
if you think about it what this is
saying this is the universe is isotropic
the same in every direction so
in that direction galaxies are moving
away from us in that direction galaxies
are moving away from us
and the further they are away from us
the faster they're moving
away from us that's what hubble's law
says so if you think about what this
looks like to different observers you
know here's an observer
they see this galaxy moving away and
they see this galaxy moving away
and closer galaxies are moving away but
more slowly
right so there's this
velocity field grows in size the further
you get away
and if you're worried about the fact
that i can pick distances such the
velocity is greater than the speed of
light
because the hubble constant is just a
constant and the distance can be
anything
well hubble's not looking nearly that
far away all these galaxies are moving
much more slowly than the speed of light
but what you notice here is that what if
you take the point of view of
this galaxy right there what if you're
living there
well then you see this galaxy moving
away from you slowly you see
us moving away from you slowly and you
see the other ones moving away from you
even faster so even though it seems to
us like everyone's moving away from us
okay
as if like we're doing something bad and
they're trying to get away and we're at
the center of some
evacuation this particular law
velocity equals some constant times
distance is exactly what you would
expect
not if we're at the center and
everyone's moving away from us
but if everything is moving away from
everything else
uniformly and that's exactly just what
general relativity predicts
so the unifor the universe is completely
homogeneous it's the same
everywhere there's no center there's no
central point so all hubble said
was that there's this relationship
between velocity and distance
but the whole story hangs together with
this idea of a uniform universe
expanding
so we can think about that a little more
quantitatively okay
so expanding universe
within the context of general relativity
now by the way when hubble
discovered this einstein was was
purportedly uh
you know reportedly uh upset that he
missed the chance to predict the
expansion or the contraction of the
universe
and he said all right we don't need the
cosmos constant anymore that was a waste
of time
but he didn't actually throw it away he
kept thinking about it of course
nowadays we've discovered it so he was
right even einstein's
biggest mistakes are our wonderful new
ideas
um so here's an expanding universe
space-time diagram time
space okay as usual and space is getting
bigger so
what does that mean space is getting
bigger
that's that's the important question
here okay so if you remember back we did
a whole biggest ideas video
on geometry where we emphasize the fact
that
from gauss and riemann and so forth we
can think of geometry
intrinsically not as some shape embedded
in a bigger space but just the
geometry of the space itself and in this
case the space is
space-time four-dimensional space-time
so you have some galaxies
okay there's a galaxy another galaxy
another galaxy
and they're expanding away from each
other and
what that means is the distance between
these galaxies is getting bigger
over time so if you say that this is a
distance
d1 and this is d2 the distance of those
two galaxies at two different times
t1 t2 then
we can define something called the scale
factor
which says the relative distance between
different galaxies okay a of
t and how this is defined is you know
the relationship
distance two divided by distance one the
relative size
is the scale factor at time t two
divided by the scale factor at time
t one and the reason why this is worth
going into
and being explicit about is because you
know people wonder about a bunch of
things you know
how can the universe expand if it's
infinitely big
you know this this space could go on
forever
how does an infinitely big universe get
bigger well the answer is the
relative distance between different
objects grows bigger if you think on the
number line think of the integers right
minus 2 minus 1
0 1 2 3 i can multiply every integer by
2.
so it becomes minus 4 minus 2 0 plus 2
plus 4 right
so i'm expanding everything by a factor
of 2. the integers got further apart
but i didn't make any more integers
right i didn't make any more numbers i
just
moved them apart from each other that's
what is going on here they're an infant
number of integers before and after
there's an infinitely big space before
and after that's completely compatible
with space expanding
and that expansion is intrinsic so
things to note about this picture of the
universe there are many things to know
this is
cosmology right one it's not expanding
into anything
that's not what's going on
so people are constantly asking you know
what is the universe expanding
into and that's because
we're used to visualizing things inside
three-dimensional space
number one and number two even
cosmologists tend to give examples that
are embedded
in three-dimensional space so they say
you know imagine a loaf of bread with
raisins and you put in the oven and it
expands or imagine a balloon with little
dots and you expand it
i don't like any of these analogies
because they're all
asking you to visualize something that's
embedded in a bigger space and that
leads you to ask
what is the universe expanding into but
it's not expanding into anything
if you want to visualize the expansion
of the universe
visualize it's being inside the universe
standing outside on a dark night
visualize having perfect vision so you
can see all the galaxies in the sky
and they're all moving away from you
they're all shrinking in size and
getting dimmer because they're moving
away from you that's what it means
to say that the universe is expanding uh
number two as we've said there's no
center
okay everything is moving away from
everything else so d1 and d2 are
increasing but then this is also
increasing
nothing is picked out as a preferred
location in the middle or anything like
that
and also you know we said that space is
uniform
that's part of the uniformity of the
universe
so what that means in terms of the
geometry of space
is that space has a constant curvature
so remember back again again when we
talked about geometry
there was loboshevsky in boye who
invented negatively curved geometry
and that is indeed a kind of
non-euclidean geometry
just like positively curved geometry on
the sphere is
but i quickly emphasized that these were
just very very special cases
real geometries tend to be lumpy not you
know this perfectly smooth
thing that boy and lobozhevsky were
talking about or a sphere is
so in you know the geometry of
space-time in the solar system
is not anything simple like positively
curved negatively curved zero
right it's it's something much more
complicated than that but for cosmology
now it works now since cut since the
universe is such a simple place
the geometry of our three-dimensional
space on the largest scales
on cosmological scales really is
either positively curved like a sphere
positive curvature it could be flat
which is zero curvature right or it
could be negatively curved like a saddle
shape
which is the sort of hyperbolic geometry
the pul
uh bulyai and lobashevsky i almost said
bolashevsky
bojaya and lebashevsky were originally
talked about so the three-dimensional
versions i've drawn little cartoons of
two-dimensional spaces but
the intrinsic geometry is dealing with
questions like if i set off two light
light beams that are parallel to each
other do they stay parallel same
distance apart forever
maybe they diverge or they eventually
come together that's what's asking
whether you're positively curved
negatively curved or flat
and indeed empirically we seem to be
here this is
the real world the measure we've
measured now years later we've measured
the curvature of space to good accuracy
to a percent or something like that
and it's within the accuracy it is flat
the universe seems to be flat could have
been
positively curved or negatively curved
seems to be flat as a matter of fact
so if you want to know does space go on
forever
if space were uniformly curved and the
curvature was positive
it would not go on forever right a
sphere it would close in on itself
but for flat or negatively curved for
both of those cases
you don't know the fact that the
curvature is uniform
is not enough to tell you whether space
is infinitely big or not
clearly a flat universe could go on
forever could just be
infinite in all directions likewise the
negatively curved universe same thing
you can have a saddle that
extends out forever but there are more
complicated topologies that are
finite okay so a a taurus a three taurus
which means a three-dimensional torus is
a way of saying let's take a cube
okay flat space inside but we're going
to identify
opposite sides so top and bottom get
identified
right and left get identified uh forward
and backward get identified
by identify we mean if you're walking
here you are
and you walk toward that wall you
eventually come out the other side
okay they're identified this is a
three-dimensional torus you can't draw
the whole thing without these
identifications but
it's spatially flat and finite and the
same thing with negatively curved spaces
there are
negatively curved but finite spaces so
unless
we someday discover that the universe is
positively curved
we are not ever going to know
empirically whether the universe goes on
infinitely or whether it's finite we may
come to a conclusion we may decide that
it's overwhelmingly likely to be either
infinite or finite
based on some theoretical considerations
that we don't yet have
available to us but as of right now we
don't know
it's hard to see how we will ever know
okay so that's a tough question to
answer
um one that we have more purchase on is
how does the universe expand
in other words we have this scale factor
as a function of t
here's the scale factor there is time we
know it's expanding so a is increasing
right now
but what's it going to do in the future
and what did it do in the past
right that's what we're trying to ask
what is the shape of this curve
the scale factor the size of the
universe as a function of time
so actually this is exactly what
einstein's
equation is set up to tell us this is
what general relativity gives us the
ability to answer these questions
quantitatively
or at least to propose answers to them
and then to test those
ideas rigorously so let's do some
definitions
um the hubble constant remember velocity
equals hubble constant times distance
right you know you heard that
so the hubble constant which is an
observational thing
um that's the way that we characterize
how fast the universe is expanding at
any one time
the faster the universe is expanding the
bigger the relationship between velocity
and distance
so we want to relate the hubble constant
to the scale factor
so you might guess that the hubble
constant is just the slope right
d a dt the velocity
of the scale factor over time but
that can't be right because the hubble
constant is some physical thing you can
measure
it's a direct relationship between two
observable quantities
whereas a the scale factor only has
meaning
you know from up here if you change a by
a constant factor if you multiply a
times two
it disappears from this equation right
here so the overall
value of a is completely meaningless
that's bad if you want to think that it
d a dt because if i change a by a factor
of 2 here the hubble constant would
change
the way i fix that is i divide by a so
sometimes this is called just so you
know a dot
that's d a dt is sometimes called a dot
over a
and that is the definition of the hubble
constant so with that definition in mind
you can take this idea of of a flat
let's just go flat for the geometry of
the universe henceforth because it's
pretty close observationally
so flat universe plug it into einstein's
equation
ask what the relationship between
curvature and
energy is and the answer is something
called the friedman equation
alexander friedman derived an equation
for the expansion of the universe and it
says
h squared equals some constant
which happens to be 8 pi g over 3 times
rho where rho is the energy density
of space well not of space
in space the density of stuff matter
radiation
dark energy whatever you want to have
okay so
the energy answers all you need to know
because you
hypothesized that space is uniform so
we're
glossing over all the lumpiness of
galaxies and stars and things like that
we're taking the average energy density
and at every point there's an energy
density it's the same at every other
point
at the same time and it's going to
change with time as the universe expands
and this is a very very simple relation
between how
fast the universe is expanding and how
much stuff there is
in it the friedman equation so what you
want to do
is tell me what kind of energy density
is in the universe and then i can solve
this equation
right because if i look at the
definition of h here
i can rewrite the friedman equation take
the square root of both sides
multiply by a and what i get is that d a
dt
the sort of velocity of the scale factor
equals the square root of 8 pi g
over 3 a squared rho
and then rho is going to be a function
of a because as the universe expands it
will dilute
the density the cubics the amount of
energy per cubic centimeter will change
and i can solve this equation to get a
as a function of time
solve it do calculus and get a as a
function of time
there you go so i can give you some
examples
so this is the big question what is row
of a
what kind of stuff what is rho
and how does it depend on the scale
factor what is the amount of energy in
the universe and how does it change
as the universe expands so i'll give you
a couple of uh
again cosmology is very simple science
it's the best one to go into
for people who have short attention
spans the universe is a simple place
there are three kinds of energy density
that really
do more than you need for uh not more
than you but as much as you need for a
lot of
modern cosmology so one kind of energy
density
is called matter remember when we talked
about
uh i guess is when we talked we had a
biggest ideas video on matter
and we talked about the fact that the
word matter in the q a we talk about the
fact the word matter is used differently
by different kinds of scientists
cosmologists use it in the most
straightforward way matter is
particles
that move
slowly i.e
the velocity is much much less than the
speed of light speed of light is the
only universal
speed so that's what you compare it to
when you say it moves slowly
why do you care how fast the particles
are moving
well because then the energy of the
particle
remember the energy of a particle has a
contribution from
its mass m c squared plus other
contributions from its kinetic
energy etc but by the hypothesis that
the particles are moving slowly
says that the kinetic energy is not
going to be very important compared to
the
rest energy and we're going to set c
equals one so this is just m
right and then the energy density
rho which is what we're after here
that's just
m the mass of the particle the energy
per particle
times n where n is the number density
which is a fancy way of saying particles
per volume whether volume is
cubic centimeters or cubic megaparsecs
it doesn't really matter
so you have some density you have some
region of space
and it has some particles in it there
are the particles every particle has an
energy
and that energy is fixed it's m c
squared per
and for whatever the m is of that
particle and as
the universe expands the number of
particles stays the same
roughly speaking there's going to be
some some counter examples to that but
roughly speaking the number of particles
stays the same
and so it's the number density times the
mass
therefore the energy per particle that
gives you the energy density
and we know what that does you know
because space is three-dimensional
um each one of these dimensions here of
the box
is going to expand along with a the
scale factor
so the volume goes up as a
cubed that's what volume does and
therefore the density if the number of
particles stays the same the density
goes
down like one over a cubed
so n is proportional to one over
a cubed and therefore rho is
proportional to let's just call it a to
the minus three so rho
matter this is matter this is what we
mean by matter as a cosmologist
a bunch of particles moving slowly
compared to the speed of light so this
is what cosmologists think of as matter
uh some energy density that dilutes away
as the universe expands and the way it
dilutes away
is that it's proportional to a to the
minus three
that is in contrast with what
cosmologists call radiation
now you think you know what radiation is
electromagnetic radiation
gravitational radiation it sounds like
massless
particles right but in fact two
cosmologists
radiation are particles moving
at the speed of light okay so massless
particles count
right photons gravitons but also
any particle that is traveling very very
fast compared to the speed of light
count or sorry near the speed of light
any particle that is almost moving the
speed of light
to a cosmologist that counts as
radiation
why because what we care about is this
relationship
between energy density and the scale
factor
and the energy density in fast moving
particles
will evolve the same way whether those
particles are moving at exactly the
speed of light or just really really
close okay
and the reason why this is true is
because of that redshift
uh the redshift
which we already mentioned hubble used
it to discover the expansion of the
universe
the wavelength of a particle
is proportional to the wavelength of a
single photon for example
is proportional to the scale factor this
is just saying that as the universe
expands
so here's time the universe is expanding
and i have a little photon its
vibrations stretch along with the
universe and you might say well how do i
know that
well you have to solve the equations you
don't know that a priori right you have
to actually say well what equations does
this solve
and you find out that it does in fact
expand along with the universe
and in other words the frequency
of the particle which is proportional to
i'm calling it a particle okay it's a
wave but you could observe it and see
that it's a particle
frequencies are proportional to one over
the wavelength and therefore to a to the
minus one
and we know back when we did quantum
mechanics the energy
of a single photon is h
times the frequency where h is uh
planck's
constant and um therefore that is also
proportional to a to the minus one per
radiation particle
okay therefore the
energy density in radiation which is the
energy per particle
per particle p for particle uh times the
number density that's still
true is proportional to a to the minus
one
times a to the minus three therefore the
energy density and radiation
is proportional to a to the minus four
there we go so conceptually what happens
is
the number density of radiation
particles photons or whatever it could
be electrons if they're moving at the
speed of light
for the electron the momentum will also
slow down
for massive particles the momentum in an
expanding universe
decreases like one over the scale factor
so they will lose energy
in exactly this way so for radiation
particles
the number density goes down like the
volume goes up but also the energy per
particle
is going down and therefore the whole
effect is that
the energy density of radiation scales
is a to the minus four
you know i paused when i was thinking
about the little h being for planck's
constant because
we've already talked about capital h
being the hubble constant and it
it just brings home this thing that i
like to point out
that the first half of the 20th century
really the first 30 or 40 years
um man it was the most exciting period
in the history of physics like so many
things were discovered relativity
quantum mechanics
those are the famous ones but also the
big bang cosmology
radiation quantum field theory you know
so many things both special and general
relativity
all in the first half of the 20th
century we were spoiled by that
like physics now is like a lot more
normal
in some sense than it was then that was
a very very unique time in the history
of physics
okay last thing to mention um
well let me go let me say a little bit
more about the the particles
so so for massive particles by massive i
mean
not zero mass i mentioned this but let
me actually draw a graph to make it
clear um the velocity the the momentum
of a particle
p is proportional to 1 over a the scale
factor so
if i draw the velocity of a massive
particle
as the scale factor is increasing as the
universe is expanding
it it has a maximum value at one right
it can't go faster than the speed of
light it has a minimum value at zero
and so roughly speaking it will always
look like this
so if you want to know the reason why i
thought this was important to to uh
say is that that's not really worth
doing this but
why do cosmologists get away with these
two
limiting cases where particles have zero
velocity or particles are going at the
speed of light and they're either matter
or their radiation
well this is the answer because
particles are going to go through their
life
most of the time they'll either be
radiation
or they'll be matter there's only a
relatively short period of their life
when their velocity is somewhere
interestingly in between
one and zero it quickly goes from one to
zero as the universe expands roughly
speaking
that's why these two categories are very
very useful
final category is vacuum
we've already talked about this empty
space cosmological constant
rho lambda for the vacuum is just
constant
so that's a to the zero it doesn't
evolve at all
right it's the same density and this
reminds us
that the thing that you would normally
call
energy in a region of space that is
expanding is not conserved
in an expanding universe you might have
thought it was if you thought that
the whole universe were made of matter
right because the energy per particle
stays the same and the number of
particles stays the same
but either for radiation or for vacuum
energy is not conserved in a co-moving
region so this is what we call
if you draw these little you know boxes
and you let the box get bigger over time
region of space that has a certain
volume this is a co-moving volume it
expands along with the expansion of the
universe
and the energy in the co-moving volume
does not stay the same
if the universe were nothing but
radiation the energy in that box would
decrease
with time if the if the universe is
mostly
vacuum energy then the energy in that
box increases with time either way it's
not conserved decreasing with time is
just as much not conserved
as increasing with time that's not to
say all hell has broken loose there's
still a relationship between what
happens to the energy and how space time
expands
but the energy is not the simple one
that you would have gotten
in flat space time one way of thinking
about this is we talked about symmetries
and nerd's theorem
you see why all these previous ideas
videos are relevant right
we did we found the fact from the
symmetry video
that invariance over time leads to
energy conservation
but the universe is expanding then the
the sort of the world in which particles
live is not invariant over time the
universe is expanding so you wouldn't
expect energy to be conserved in the
usual way
and given those three options for what
can be the stuff in the universe
we can go and solve the friedman
equation remember the freedom equation
is h
squared which is a dot over a
squared is 8 pi g
over 3 rho which now we know for
different options we could have rho as a
function of adding right
and so for matter domination
matter domination means most of the
energy density in the universe comes
from matter
well then rho goes like row matter goes
like a to the minus three
and the freedom equation we can plug in
and solve and we get that a
is proportional to t to the two thirds
you can check this at home then you know
a dot
proportional t to the minus one third
one third
and you can check at home that it solves
the freedom equation likewise for
radiation domination
uh rho radiation proportional to a to
the minus four
and you get that a goes like t to the
one half
and for vacuum domination
rho lambda is proportional a to the zero
and then it's a little bit trickier but
a is proportional to
e to the t the only thing is that
t needs to be multiplied by a constant
to be dimensionless because you
exponentiate dimensionless numbers
and the thing you multiply by is
basically the hubble constant or some
particular hubble constant which i'm
calling h star
some particular hubble constant
corresponding to that vacuum energy
so that's it that's exactly how easy it
is to solve for the expansion of the
universe
in cosmology and you can even check
yourself
but okay not done yet all i've done is
given you three options for what could
be in the universe
so let's get to reality now what really
is in the universe and what really was
and what will be in the universe will
the universe be matter dominate
radiation dominate vacuum dominate or
whatever so let's let's think let's use
our brains before we start uh
making guesses here um the past of the
universe
well what do we know we know that right
now uh we live in the universe
and there's stuff in it um particles
galaxies stars but there's also light
right you know emitted from stars and
and other kinds of light also and we
know that as we
expand the universe the light stretches
it goes from shorter wavelengths to
longer wavelengths
and what that means is that in some
sense the universe is cooling down
right a colder black body radiation has
longer wavelengths than
hotter black body radiation so what that
means in the
past the universe was smaller the scale
factor was smaller
um and therefore the radiation was
shorter wavelength and therefore it was
hotter so in the past
the universe was hotter in some sense
okay
um in fact you can you can show that
in the right circumstances where new
particles are not being created or
destroyed
temperature is proportional to one over
the scale factor
so we often do is we plot a log log plot
so the logarithm of the temperature as a
function of the logarithm of the scale
factor
to be perfectly honest i forgot i've
forgotten whether i've explained what a
log is i must have explained what a log
is right
the logarithm of e to the x
equals x logarithm is the
operation that undoes exponentiation so
when you have two variables that are
related by one
is the other one to some power like t is
a to the power -1 then on a log log plot
you get a straight line
and indeed here's the straight line so
as the universe expands the temperature
goes down okay so what we can do is we
can think about the
thermal history of the universe in fact
this is so this relationship is so nice
that very often if i
if i tell you you know something was
happening when the scale factor was 10
to the minus nine of what it is now
you don't really have a feeling for what
that means okay scale factor is a
billionth of what it is now i'm not
really sure what's going on then
but if i tell you what is happening when
the temperature was let's say
a million electron volts then you can
relate that in your brain since you've
listened to the other videos about
particles and matter and atoms
right scales and other videos so you
know what all these particles have is
their masses and so forth and you go oh
yeah okay so that's
heavier than a neutrino it's about the
mass of an electron
so you know you can instantly know which
particles are
heavy compared to the temperature and
therefore moving slowly
which particles are light compared to
the temperature and therefore moving
rapidly right
so we'll we'll talk about the thermal
history we'll think about the history of
the universe
as a function of temperature but you
know that's a proxy for thinking of it
as the function of the scale factor
and so what happens as you heat things
up you know the universe gets hotter and
hotter
let's imagine that you you know take a
box with let's imagine we simplify our
lives
you have a box that has just photons in
it and you make it smaller right and you
might say well okay the photons
get more and more energetic they get
smaller and smaller wavelength in a
contracting universe
right but that's not all that happens
because you know
that photons can convert into other
particles by interacting with each other
so you can have you know two photons
gamma plus gamma two photons convert
into
an electron and a positron so here's a
feynman diagram that makes that happen
gamma gamma e minus e plus
uh let's draw a little fermion lines
voila a conversion from electrons to
photons
and you can go the other way to an
electron and a positron can
annihilate into two photons so this is a
conversion back and forth
and what happens is if the typical
wavelength of the photons
or the typical energy of the photons is
much
less than the mass of the electrons this
is never going to happen
right because the photons don't have
enough energy to make two real
electrons or an electron and a positron
so
when t the temperature
which is another way of thinking about
the typical energy of the particles
is greater than let's say two times the
mass of the electron
this happens in fact
let's say it happens rapidly
and it happens rapidly in both
directions so what i'm saying is
you start with a nothing but photons and
you contract the universe
those photons are going to be photons
and get more and more energetic
once they're energetic enough to pair
create
electron positron pairs then you're
going to go from
a box of just photons to a box of a
combination
of photons and electrons and positrons
okay
and you say well the electrons and
positrons are going to annihilate away
yes they will into photons which will
then create more electrons and positrons
so you get an equilibrium where this
where this reaction goes back and forth
very very rapidly and in fact if you're
at temperatures way higher
than the mass of the electron there are
approximately equal numbers
of photons and electrons and positrons
roughly speaking
so that's the trick to all of the
thermal history of the universe
once the temperature goes above the mass
of a particle
then that particle can be created very
very
efficiently and therefore that particle
becomes part of the radiation gas
the particle will also be relativistic
as we say it moves close to the speed of
light
because you're at a temperature much
much greater than the mass of that
particle
so its energy would be greater than its
mass therefore its moving near the speed
of light
therefore its radiation uh not just
matter
so another way of saying this is
uh if you were to plot so
what we mean is so what we're saying
here let's let's let's back up i was
going to rush ahead a little bit
um what this is saying is that it
seems like the energy density of the
universe
should usually be in the form of
radiation
why because you know there's some
radiation there
and if the temperature is below the mass
of a certain particle
that particle and its antiparticle will
annihilate away into radiation
if you if the temperature is higher than
that particle
then you can then the mass of that
particle then you can make it
through this pair creation process but
when you make it because the temperature
is higher than its mass
it's relativistic and it is also
radiation
so the photons which are sort of literal
radiation make fast-moving electrons
which are sort of figurative radiation
but
to cosmologists it's all just radiation
so you might think
that the universe is almost always all
radiation
and in fact so let's run it forward now
let's go
increasing uh let the universe expand
and ask what happens to the energy
density so if it's
here's energy density again log log plot
i'm not going to say that
every single time or even write it but
energy density
versus scale factor and for
photons you get something like this
so the energy density and photons which
are always relativistic they always move
at the speed of light
that's proportional to a to the minus
four so that's a certain straight line
on this graph but what about you know
for
electrons well when the temperature is
higher than the mass then the electrons
are very similar
in density and they evolve in a very
similar way
but then when you hit the point where
the temperature is of order the mass
of the electrons they annihilate but
they don't get recreated
so the number density of electrons
plummets
okay the electrons just annihilate away
and then there's always going to be some
remnants right because you know these
numbers are never exact but it's very
very
small so this is rho electron
it's radiation-like for a while and then
it becomes
goes away quickly and this is when the
temperature
is of order the mass of the electron
which is of order
1 mev or 10 to the sixth
electron volts okay so
this is what leads you to believe that
you know maybe
the universe should just be full of
radiation all the time
how could you get anything else well
there are three exceptions
to this rule one of them you probably
already guessed
uh namely that this only makes sense
if there are an equal number of
electrons and positrons okay so one
exception
is an asymmetry
between
particles and anti-particles
so that's what actually happens that's
what you and i are made of right and we
talked about this
uh the idea of bariogenesis there were a
number of quarks and baryons which are
the particles that quarks make up
um and there was an imbalance in the
early universe between the number of
particles number of quarks the number of
antiquarks
and so almost all one all but one in a
billion
quarks annihilated away because of
exactly a process like this
we believe uh but there was a little
remnant left over because now you know
the atoms the protons and neutrons that
are around us
there aren't any anti-protons and
anti-neutrons hanging around
for them to annihilate you might ask you
know
is it possible like other galaxies are
made of antimatter
but the universe is not quite as empty
as you might think even though
interstellar space is
pretty darn empty there's still some gas
and dust
there and so if another galaxy was made
of antimatter
there's some region in between the two
galaxies where there would constantly be
particles and anti-particles bumping
into each other annihilating and giving
off high-intensity radiation
so that is not observed so no
anti-particles and other galaxies are
not made of antimatter they're all made
of matter
so this is one way to get you know more
particles than antiparticles and
therefore matter
and in this case in the real world case
it's called bariogenesis
and we mentioned why is it variogenesis
not leptogenesis or electron genesis
we don't know if the number of leptons
is
bigger or smaller than the number of
anti-leptons because there are
neutrinos in the universe and we cannot
count how many neutrinos there are
versus anti-neutrinos whereas we can
count the number of baryons
there you go another possible exception
is just that the interactions the
annihilations
are weak you know if the particles
don't interact with each other that much
you know the particles in order to
interact
in order to annihilate they have to hit
each other and annihilate right
for electrons and positrons this isn't
so hard they have long range
electromagnetic forces they will find
each other and annihilate
but maybe you have some hypothetical
particle
like maybe a weakly interacting massive
particle
that interacts weakly and it's massive
so they
at some point the universe becomes
sufficiently dilute
that these particles no longer
annihilate away in other words
for wimps the universe might very well
have
an equal number of wimps and anti-wimps
it's just they never find each other to
annihilate the weak interaction that
they use to annihilate is not long range
remember it's very very short range so
the two wimps need to come really really
close to each other
in order to annihilate so it doesn't
happen that often so you just get
what is called a thermal relic
because these are particles that were
once in equilibrium at high temperature
they were popping in and out of
existence but then as the universe
expanded and cooled
they just stopped annihilating because
the density went down they couldn't find
each other anymore
finally there's sort of a grab bag for
other things um
non-thermal relics
so if you have particles that are
massive
but that we're never in thermal
equilibrium so let's imagine particles
that interact with each other
so weakly that they never were either
created or destroyed by all these
photons bumping into each other but
there could be some other mechanism for
making them
so i'm not going to go into details but
axions
are another dark matter candidate
which people talk about very popular
second most popular dark matter
candidate
after wimps and axions are created by
various non-thermal production
mechanisms
so i'm not going to go into t as like i
said you can google the word axion you
can find out all about them
and you'll you'll realize that there are
different ways to have particles left
over so
this very naive story in which the
universe is always just radiation
because particles that become heavy
annihilate away there are very very
important exceptions to this that's why
there can be
matter in the universe okay so
because of that therefore thus
the generic thing we expect for the
evolution of
the energy density of the universe rho
versus the scale factor is
at super high temperatures uh the
universe will indeed be dominated by
radiation there are photons and
and gravitons and so forth but there are
also
every other particle being created and
destroyed and
all moving close to the speed of light
because we're at super high temperatures
and the temperature is much higher than
the masses of those particles so there's
a component of radiation
in the universe and it decays away
quickly as a to the minus four
but then there's also some leftover
heavy particles like protons and
neutrons or maybe like wimp or other
dark matter particles
and those their energy density
goes away dilutes away more slowly right
it dilutes away like a to the minus
three
so r is proportional to a to the minus
four
but matter it'll start subdominant but
it will eventually catch up
so here is matter proportional a to the
minus three
okay so we expect is that early times
the universe is radiation dominated
but if you have some mechanism that
gives you leftover particles
eventually leftover massive particles
eventually they will dominate
and the universe will become matter
dominated even if there's very very few
of them
if you wait long enough because they
dilute away more slowly in energy
density
eventually they're going to win then of
course
finally if you have any vacuum energy at
all
eventually eventually that's going to
win because vacuum energy is just
constant
on this plot right so vacuum
is just a to the zero so that will
always win
so this is the generic expectation for
how the universe evolves it's radiation
dominated early times then it's matter
dominated then it's vacuum dominated and
i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna sort of reveal that this
is all terribly mistaken this is right
we think that this is exactly correct
in broad strokes there can be details uh
that change here
um good there's
i guess there's one thing that is worth
saying here what is that little symbol
is that just a badly drawn a
yeah one thing worth saying here
which is that what about this vacuum
dominated regime
so vacuum dominance it's worth saying a
few more words
i said um that a
is proportional to e to some specific
hubble constant value
times time and you might ask well
you know you can even check this right d
a
dt is then equal to h star
times e to the h star t this is the nice
thing is why
e the specific constant is so nice
because the derivative of e to the x
is just e to the x the derivative of e
to the
some constant times x brings down the
constant and then you get e to the x
again
so this is equal to h star times a and
you can plug in the friedman equation
and you can see that it works
so this is another way of saying that a
fixed amount of energy vacuum energy
cosmological constant
imparts a perpetual impulse that expands
the universe
at a constant rate and what you see is
the scale factor
going exponentially right an exponential
looks like
it expands very quickly exponentially
fast as it were
um and so this is it's clear why this
counts as an accelerating universe right
because
if you think about the hubble hubble law
velocity equals
h times d uh the distance
to something is increasing
and this is the the thing about this
particular vacuum domination thing
is that this constant h star is actually
truly constant
so this is why i wanted to get the
nomenclature right we talk about the
hubble constant
and when we talk about the hubble
constant we're referring to the
value of the hubble of the hubble
parameter
today right so in general relativity we
define
one over a times da dt as the hubble
parameter
and that's different at different eras
in the history of the universe in the
early universe
the density was much higher and the
hubble parameter was much larger than it
is today so the hubble constant in other
words
isn't really a constant if you define it
or calculate it at different moments in
time
but if the universe has nothing in it
but vacuum
nothing in it but a cosmological
constant then there's a constant energy
density
and remember from the friedman equation
remember friedman
says h squared
is eight pi g over three rho
and if rho is constant all these other
things are constant so h is constant so
that's h
star so h star squared is the vacuum
energy density
times 8 pi g over 3. and so
that gets a little surprising because
you're saying well wait a minute
i told you before that the hubble
parameter is the way that we
characterize the expansion rate of the
universe
and you're telling me now that expansion
rate is constant so why is that
accelerating why is a constant expansion
rate
accelerating well it's because if
this expansion rate is constant the
velocity
that you would observe of any distant
galaxy will be increasing over time
right so if the distance is increasing
if this is constant
then the velocity that we observe will
be increasing
so that's really observationally why we
call it an accelerating universe because
distant galaxies
accelerate away from us so this is a
feature of non-euclidean geometry that
we have in
the expanding universe in general
relativity that on the one hand
the expansion rate is constant if you
were to calculate the riemann tensor
the curvature of space-time in the
universe like this it would be
constant it would not be changing over
time
but we say the universe is accelerating
at the same time the expansion rate is
constant and the universe is
accelerating
why well because that's how the geometry
works it's just yet to go a little bit
beyond your conventional intuition a
little bit
but you should be able to do that okay
so what i want to do is to sort of
close up here well there's a lot to say
you know
there's a lot of cosmology out there so
you're going to indulge me with a lot of
a lot of knowledge we got to drop in
this particular biggest ideas video
we talked about the fact that the
friedman equation tells you how fast the
universe is expanding we talked about
the fact that there's matter radiation
in vacuum as different examples we even
talked about the fact that electrons
would be relativistic and part of the
radiation
at high temperatures or they'll be
matter at low temperatures
let's go through the actual history of
the universe a little bit about that
thermal history that we talked about
for the real world and so this sort of
brings things together you know even
though cosmology is
fundamentally simple it involves little
bits and pieces of all the physics that
is out there so that's why i keep
mentioning
previous installments in the biggest
ideas series because cosmology really
brings together a lot of different ideas
from a lot of different areas of physics
so particle physics in particular is
going to be
relevant here so let's start the
universe at high temperatures and then
let it expand and cool
and see what happens so we need to ask
you know how high is high what counts as
high temperature
uh by this way of counting the
philosophy we have here
at the biggest ideas is that we're
trying to tell you ideas we think are
true
that is to say we have very very good
reason to think that they're correct
um we're trying you know i'm happy to
speculate occasionally but that's not
the point
so a lot of discussions of cosmology go
instantly to you know the big
bang inflation and the multiverse and
stuff like that but
i'm trying to tell you what actually
happens in the world and then we can
see what we'll speculate about in
uh in other contexts but
what do we know about the thermal
history depends on what we know about
the particles that the universe
is made of right and we get a long bunch
of conversations about the standard
model of particle physics and we have
the higgs boson the top quark and things
like that
but beyond that at energies higher than
100 or a couple hundred
billion electron volts we don't know
what is in the universe
so let's call that our cutoff at
temperature is higher than
a hundred billion electron volts that is
to say 10 to the 11
electron volts we don't know what's
going on the universe is a stew of
particles
and relativistic particles relativistic
again means
just moving close to the speed of light
and that includes standard model
and others maybe unknown particles
because we don't know grain unification
super symmetry extra dimensions who
knows what's up there
some set of relativistic degrees of
freedom as we would call them okay
we begin to know what's going on at
temperatures around
so this is radiation in case that's not
clear uh temperatures around
10 to the 11 electron volts this is you
know 100
gev 100 billion electron volts is where
the standard model
kicks in um and the first thing that
happens is
electro weak symmetry breaking
so what that means is
let me write rather than talking
we talked about this when we talked
about symmetries and matter and so forth
um
gauge theories remember gage theories
have different
phases and one of the phases of gage
theory can be in is when the symmetry
that gives rise to the gauge theory is
spontaneously broken
in particular the higgs boson breaks the
electroweak symmetry of the standard
model of particle physics
so this is what the higgs is doing and
what it's doing is
you know it has a potential v of phi
as a function of phi and the potential
looks like this
this mexican hat form right
and at higher temperatures than 10 to
the 11 gev
it's there basically because the higgs
is being buffeted around right so you
might say well why does it fall to the
bottom
well it's very hot so the field itself
is sort of vibrating and
on average it sits at zero at the middle
of its potential
and then once the universe cools down to
10 to the 11 gev
then the higgs can fall down into the
brim of the hat and the symmetry
breaking
takes place so above 100 gev
electrons and quarks are all massless
and they're identical
to neutrinos electrons and neutrinos are
identical
up and down quarks are identical et
cetera the symmetry has not yet been
broken
after that now electrons and quarks have
masses their masses are still small
compared to the temperature so they're
still relativistic but now they're
officially
massive then there's a series of big
events
series of very fortunate events so at
temperatures of around
10 to the 8 electron volts that's about
100
mev you'll sometimes hear it said this
is where
um qcd
quantum chromodynamics the strong
nuclear force
becomes strong you might remember or you
might not in that gauge theory
video uh spontaneous symmetry breaking
in the higgs
phase was one thing we talked about
another thing we talked about was the
coulomb
phase where the force lines
of a gauge theory can extend out
infinitely far you get a
coulomb like force the one over r
squared newtonian kind of potential
uh or force i should say and there's
also a confining phase where the field
where the gauge fields interact with
each other so strongly
that they just bundle up into little
particles rather than stretching out
at temperatures and we also said i
forget whether we said this i hope i
said this
qcd has the very special feature that is
called asymptotic freedom
when we talk about renormalization we
talked about the fact that the coupling
constants of theories could have
different values at different energies
it's also true at different temperatures
because temperature and energy are kind
of the same thing
at high temperatures the strong nuclear
force is weak
it is not very strong it goes to zero
strength at infinite energies or
infinite temperatures
at low temperatures it's strong so this
is the cut-off this is the dividing line
at temperatures above 10 to the 8th
electron volts
qcd is weak and therefore quarks and
gluons are not confined
into hadrons they are freely floating at
lower temperatures at temperatures below
10 to the 8th gev
now quarks and gluons confine into
hadrons
so quarks
and gluons confined
higher temperatures they were separately
moving particles lower temperatures
they're bound into protons and neutrons
and mesons and things like that
that's the next big event um what's next
at temperatures of around 10 to the
sixth electron volts
there's a there's a series of things
also going on here as particles go from
being
uh relativistic to non-relativistic they
decay away
and there's some or they annihilate away
and sort of the last
big event of that form was near one mev
where electrons
annihilate away so e plus e minus
annihilation
and this is basically the last time in
the history of the universe that a whole
bunch of particles annihilated away okay
electrons are the lightest particles
that can still annihilate away neutrinos
are lighter but they don't
annihilate away because they interact
too weakly so there's still a gas of
neutrinos all around you there's a
cosmic neutrino background but electrons
and positrons
find each other and they do an island
away at around their mass which is
around a million
electron volts so after that
now radiation
by radiation to cosmologists we now mean
photons and neutrinos
at higher temperatures we meant all
sorts of other particles but at
temperatures below
an mev it's photons neutrinos you might
ask
why not gravitons you know shouldn't
gravitons like photons count
the answer is because remember we
mentioned if particles interact weakly
enough
then they might never have been in
thermal equilibrium they might never
have been produced or they might never
have annihilated into other particles
gravitons count gravitons interact so
weakly there's no reason for them to
ever have been
in equilibrium so the actual particles
that are there in the background are
mostly
photons and neutrinos as far as we know
there could be some gravitons there that
we don't know about but the
dominant sources are photons and
neutrinos to be said another way
you know those electrons and positrons
just like
up quarks and down quarks and taus and
so forth these all these particles
existed
and when they annihilate they annihilate
the photons they don't violate the
gravitons
so even if there were a lot of gravitons
in the very early universe by the time
you've been through all these stages
you're left with photons and neutrinos
that's what that's what you're actually
left with and you can calculate
exactly how many and this is one of the
things you learn to do if you're a
cosmology graduate student you calculate
the ratio of neutrinos to photons in the
universe
and then there's a crucially important
phase at ten to the
five electron volts okay uh
which is big bang nucleosynthesis
big bang nucleus bag big bang
nucleosynthesis
i think i have that temperature right
something like that
i should actually check that um so
or you should check it there you go
homework check that is the right
temperature but the point is it's in the
right order anyway
big bang nuclear synthesis is when
protons
and neutrons can come together
they could always come together you know
and you know you can make a proton
neutron make a deuteron
but at temperatures higher than this all
the photons hitting them would just tear
that apart
right away so they wouldn't be stable so
after this the temperature is lower than
this protons and neutrons can come
together to make deuterium
helium and lithium okay
now you might say so there's another
question here um
well good these are like the lightest
things you could have made
out of protons and neutrons why did you
stop
there why don't you make carbon and
oxygen and so forth so this is
all this theory is worked out by george
gamows ralph alpher
and i think it's robert herman 1950s and
60s
they're really the pioneers of the big
bang by the way there's a shameful story
about nobel prizes here you know edwin
hubble never won the nobel prize for
discovering the expansion of the
universe
gamov and his collaborators never won
the nobel prize for the big bang theory
uh even though they should have it's
kind of a weird thing that i don't quite
understand
but anyway um we live in a world where
in the universe where there's a whole
bunch of different kinds of chemical
elements right
there is carbon and there's all the way
up like iron and uranium and lead in
in the universe here on earth where did
they come from if the universe started
with nothing but protons and neutrons
it was very natural to think that they
were produced in the big bang
right because you know the particles
protons neutrons come together and make
heavier elements until eventually the
universe cools down
when you run the numbers it doesn't work
that way because there's a competition
yes protons and neutrons are coming
together to fuse together to form
heavier elements
but the universe is also expanding and
becoming less dense
and all of these nuclei are positively
charged right electromagnetically
they're repelling
each other not attracting so it just
very quickly you go from a phase where
protons and neutrons can't even stick
together
to a phase where they can't fuse
together anymore
in the first place and in that tiny
window which is the big bang
nucleosynthesis window
when the universe was a few seconds or a
few minutes old
that's when you could make elements you
end up making mostly helium
a little bit of deuterium and lithium
that's why steven weinberg's famous
popular book on cosmology is called the
first three minutes
that's when nucleosynthesis was going on
and
this is worth a whole you know if i were
more ambitious or didn't have other
things to do
big bang nucleosynthesis sounds pretty
down to earth
but oh sorry i didn't finish the story
um
therefore you didn't make all the
heavier elements in the big bang you
make them in stars
so roughly speaking you know the
universe is mostly hydrogen and helium
that helium was produced in the big bang
these trace amounts of deuterium and
lithium were also produced in the big
bang but
everything else was produced in stars
either exploding or just spitting out
heavier elements so the interiors of
stars or supernova explosions
were necessary to produce heavier
elements okay
and this is worth a huge amount of
exploration because
we know enough physics to say more or
less exactly what was happening
at big bang nuclear synthesis so we're
talking literally a second after the big
bang or a few seconds after the big bang
and this depends on the expansion rate
of the universe which therefore depends
on the energy density of the universe
which therefore depends on
photons and neutrinos right so you say
well
there are three families of neutrinos
people asked in other q and a videos how
do you know there are more
families of elementary particles right
we have three generations or three
families how do you know there aren't
four
well if there were four light neutrinos
the energy density of the universe would
have been a little bit different
during big bang nucleosynthesis because
that fourth neutrino would also have
contributed to the radiation energy
density
and that means the hubble parameter
would have been a little bit different
and that means the expansion of the
universe would have been a little bit
different and that means the relative
abundance
of hydrogen helium lithium and deuterium
predicted by big bang nuclear synthesis
would have been different
and when you compare to the data the
prediction with three neutrinos is right
and a prediction with four neutrinos is
wrong
furthermore even better you say you know
you
think you know you have this dark matter
stuff how do you know this dark matter
stuff isn't just
protons and neutrons that you haven't
found maybe they're just dark
well the ratio of the number of protons
to the number of
photons is crucially important for big
bang nucleosynthesis
if there were fewer photons they'd be
less efficient at breaking apart the
nuclei
if there were more photons they'd be too
efficient at breaking them apart
we know how many photons there are in
the universe because we can look at them
they're mostly in the cosmic microwave
background
therefore if we know how many photons
there are in the universe
and we know that big bang
nucleosynthesis works we
know how many protons and neutrons there
are in the universe
we know the total amount of ordinary
matter
in the universe and it's much less than
the total amount of matter
that's one of the best reasons to think
we need dark matter
so this big band nucleosynthesis story
is incredibly important and i encourage
you if you're not already
familiar with it read all about it it's
really one of the triumphs of modern
cosmology you know i remember
again when i was in grad school
cosmology was
in the process of going from slightly
disreputable
to a really central part of modern
physics you know really is as
as recently as the 80s and 90s people
were a little skeptical
and i won't name names but you know i
ran into famous particle physicists who
were like you don't believe that big
bang
synthesis stuff do you like that that
really constrains the number of
neutrinos
it really does it really did it got
everything right you know uh david
schramm
and other people get a lot of credit for
figuring that stuff out
okay um then when the temperature
is of order uh 10 electron volts between
1 and 10 electron volts finally
nuclei mostly hydrogen and helium in
fact mostly hydrogen
and electrons can come together to form
atoms
and this is the process known as
recombination
some people make fun of the word
recombination in this context
in laboratory physics when you take an
atom and you ionize it so you remove the
electron and then you let the electron
come back you call that recombination
so therefore in cosmology when the
electron comes back to the atom we also
use the same word recombination so some
people try to be clever and say
shouldn't it just be combination since
it's the first time it ever happened
so if you ever meet one of those
unfortunate people
who are trying to be pedantic and
annoying you can prove that you are even
more pedantic and annoying by saying
actually recombination is appropriate
because a typical atom an electron or a
typical atom let's say
will gain an electron and then lose it
and gain it and lose it
many many many times before finally it
gains its final electron in the history
of
cosmology so it is actually
recombination
uh but it's a crucially important stage
in the history of the universe because
when those electrons are flying freely
the universe is opaque right photons
keep bumping into those electrons
so you wouldn't be able to see your hand
in front of your face uh before
recombination
after recombination when the universe is
all atoms
now photons can travel freely so this is
when the universe becomes transparent
and what that means is all that light
all those photons
that we had running around all through
space
can suddenly stream freely through the
universe and we call that the background
radiation the cosmic
microwave background and this you know
helps us
understand a little bit about people ask
like
why is the cosmic microwave background
hitting us right now you know how does
it know
so let's just think about exactly what's
going on here again we have our usual
space time diagram for the universe okay
space
and the point is uh
we have photons going in all directions
at every point in space okay there's no
special point in space
no central point or anything like that
as space expands and the universe cools
photons are still there they're now
slightly longer wavelengths
same number of photons i have to draw
the same number of arrows whatever that
was
uh one two three one three four there
you go
okay but they cool down the temperature
goes down right so they were
short wavelength you know they were 10
electron volts
the temperature today 2.7 kelvin
which is about 10 to the minus 4
electron volts here the temperature
was between 1 and 10
electron volts and this this moment so
now the universe is 14
let's say 13.8 i think billion years
giga years after the big bang uh and
here this moment of recombination
is 380 000 years
after the big bang so it's been a long
time this is still
relatively early in the universe's
history and here we are
you know today and we look back at our
past
light cone so our light cone
intersects this recombination uh
moment in some sphere and so it doesn't
matter
where we were if there were some other
if there were some aliens who lived here
in some other galaxy they would look
back and their light cone would
intersect
the surface or this time of
recombination and they would see
a cosmic microwave background there's
always some photons moving exactly along
those light cones no matter what lycone
you're talking about
so it's not that the cosmic microwave
background is
literally a sphere it's just that the
sky
looks like a sphere to us everywhere in
the universe the universe is suffused
with these
relic photons from the big bang that we
call the cosmic microwave background
okay it's the same
overall features for the cosmic
microwave background in all places
it's a snapshot of what the universe
looked like 380
000 years after the big bang so the two
big events that we love in observational
cosmology are big bang nuclear synthesis
and recombination because those give us
observational data
about what the universe was doing at
early times and the big
nuclear synthesis is still a story of um
a uniform universe you know that we
the differences in density from place to
place are not that large
but the microwave background
recombination now
the tiny differences in density from
place to place
suddenly become important so that's why
the cmb
is like the growth industry like this is
where well i mean it's already grown
it's a huge industry
if you want to be a modern theoretical
cosmologist you got to know the cosmic
microwave background in and out and this
leads us directly into
this uh the next feature of what we're
saying here
which is that so far we've taken
very seriously the idea that the
universe is perfectly smooth
okay and that gets us very very far so
to sort of in the last few
last few topics here very quickly let's
let the universe be a little bit
lumpy right the universe is not
perfectly smooth
so the universe isn't perfectly smooth
and we can characterize that
quantitatively
we can say that there's a difference in
density from place to place
call that delta rho okay
so delta rho well you know the energy
density itself which is rho
that's changing as the universe expands
likewise delta rho is changing it's hard
to remember what it is
so we take delta o we divide it by rho
so this is the fractional difference in
energy density
from place to place in the universe so
delta rho
of x and roughly speaking on average
in the early universe it's ten to the
minus five
okay so one part in a hundred thousand
so if in one region of space
there is a hundred thousand atoms then
in a nearby region
on average they'll be a hundred thousand
one
or ninety nine thousand nine hundred
ninety nine okay they'll be fluctuations
of order one part in a thousand overall
and what we can do this is a very
traditional physics-y move to analyze
you know what this means is well
sorry before i analyze it let me just
mention something that should be obvious
but you know maybe it's worth saying
um these tiny perturbations
this is literally a perturbation by
which you mean a tiny change 10-5 is a
small amount
the tiny perturbations
grow
by uh
gravitational instability
which is a fancy way of saying that
a slightly over dense region will
pull itself together under gravity and
also pull gas and dust and matter from
regions around
it so it will become even more over
dense whereas an under dense region
will lose its matter to nearby overdense
regions so it becomes even more
under dense so that's why it's an
instability okay the
tiny variations will grow with time okay
and that
they grow into galaxies and stars and
planets and things like that so it's
kind of a big deal
the universe right now 14 billion years
after the big bang is much lumpier
than it was in the very early universe
but
i don't want to that's i just wanted to
say that so you know what's going to
eventually happen but i'm not going to
go into a lot of details about that
let's
think about the early universe let's
think about
these tiny fluctuations in density in
the early universe and let's analyze
them that's why i used the word analyze
before so
how do we analyze it well we don't
know what the density of the universe is
at any one point
right like that's just a uh it could be
big could be small
who knows how do i even know what point
we're talking about what we do
is same thing we do with wavelengths of
light we do a fourier transform
we look at modes of different
wavelengths and so we analyze
the fluctuations in density not from
point to point in space
but scale to scale we say on large
distances what is the variation in
density on small distances what is the
variation density
and so forth and at early times we think
and we'll go back to why that's true at
the end but we think that
it was basically the same story at every
scale there were scale-free
perturbations in density so density
perturbations
are approximately not exactly and that
becomes important but not for us we're
not going to
that much detail
scale free which is a fancy
way of saying the same amount of
fluctuation at every distance that we
might want to
quantify it at okay so
what you can do is say well let's
analyze that by looking at the cosmic
microwave background you could analyze
it today by looking at galaxies right
and you do believe me that's large-scale
structure
study is one of the things that you do
as a working cosmologist
but it's much harder it's much messier
because by now the this gravitational
instability has led to an enormous
variation in density like the center of
the sun is way more
dense than the space in between the
galaxies okay
that becomes harder to analyze it's this
small variation that you have at early
times
this i should say like early primordial
small variation that's truly a
perturbation
anything that's just a small variation
from simplicity is much easier to
analyze than large
deviations from simplicity so even
though large-scale structure and
galaxies
are an important source of cosmological
information
when the micro background was formed the
snapshot of the universe at
early times is way easier to analyze
and to predict and so that's why it's
been such a treasure trove for
cosmologists you know it was only 1992
uh that the kobe satellite actually
measured
slight deviations in temperature in the
cosmic microwave background
so uh the cmb causing microarray
background
has the property that these fluctuations
in density from place to place
translate into fluctuations in the
temperature of the cmb we said you know
2.7 kelvin
on average is the temperature that you
get from the cmb but it's not exactly
that
for a long time since we discovered in
the 60s up until 92 it was exactly that
and finally we found small variations
delta t over t
of order ten to the minus five okay and
you can look at them at different angles
on the sky
so basically you can ask this question
about density perturbations
as a function of distance but you can do
it on the microwave background you look
at
points close to each other what is their
variation in temperature look at points
far away what is their variation
temperature
there's math involved spherical
harmonics and things like that but
roughly it's the same kind of story that
you would do with
fourier transforms or whatever so this
becomes
an industry predict delta t over t as a
function of angular scale on the sky so
we're going to do that we're going to
predict it
we're going to get it wrong then we're
going to fix it okay so here is what you
might guess
very very naively i already said look
perturbations are approximately scale
free so that's density perturbations so
therefore
if i look at c and b temperatures
delta t over t as a function of angular
scale
and so these are by the way the usual
way that we plot this is
large scale and small scale
large scale on the left small scale on
the right why well because there is a
largest scale
on the sky 180 degrees right whereas
small scales can go infinitely small so
it makes more it's just more convenient
but large scale uh near the beginning of
the graph
what you might predict is this
right that's your guess that you get the
same amount of temperature variation at
large scales intermediate scales small
scales
because the underlying density
perturbations are the same
right there's there was some mechanism
i'm being intentionally mysterious about
this there's some mechanism
that created i guess density
perturbations that were similar at all
scales the reason i'm being mysterious
is because most cosmologists at least
many cosmologists think that inflation
in the very early universe was the
mechanism that made these perturbations
we don't know that's a speculation
that's something we don't know
but as observational cosmologists we
know that they were
approximately scale-free and you might
guess
that those approximately scale-free
primordial perturbations
turn into a flat uh
temperature variation as a function of
scale when we look at them in telescopes
on the sky
but that's not true that's not exactly
what we see it's a little bit slightly
more subtle than that and the reason why
is because
perturbations perts evolve
okay like we said if you have a slightly
over dense region it will
become more over dense gravitational
instability so there turn out to be a
number of different
mechanisms by which the perturbations
evolve
one is just exactly that gravitational
instability
so
[Music]
over dense regions
contract not literally contract in size
but you know the matter in them
contracts and becomes more dense so you
have some region of space
you have a region inside where there's
more particles than average there are
some particles outside but not as many
and the over dense region under the
force of gravity
brings together even more particles into
it okay
that's one thing that happens uh another
thing that happens
is well it's the real world
you know this is why cosmology gets
messy because all the physics matters
so if if some matter
contracts it's kind of like you know you
have a gas
in a piston and you're you're
compressing it right and you know
when you have a gas in a piston you
compress it it heats up
and you also know that when gas heats up
it pushes back
on you there's pressure that resists
right it doesn't just collapse to a
black hole
there's in a in a piston it will push
back on you you'll become
too weak to keep pushing it eventually
so that will happen here
in the real world when particles come
together they will bump into each other
they will heat up
the radiation will start pushing back on
them there will be a pressure restoring
force so we're
thinking in our minds here about times
before the microwave background
was formed okay so we're going to see
what is the effect
on the microwave background so we're
talking about
times in the history of the universe
before electrons and protons and helium
atoms came together
so the universe is not transparent it's
opaque
so those electrons and protons are
bunching together the photons keep
buffeting them around
so the second effect is contracting
regions
heat up
and develop pressure which means that
they bounce back
in fact you might think that it sounds
kind of like a sound wave or the ringing
of a bell
because it exactly is that's exactly
what it is it's an acoustic
oscillation
a sound wave is just when you know here
in the air in the room when you're
listening to me
i make slightly higher density of air
molecules and that sort of pushes on the
air molecules nearby
and in any one region any one point in
space the density goes up and down
right it vibrates up and down when you
have a sound wave
uh or literally when you bang a gong the
gong will vibrate and send out sound
waves and they go up and down in density
as
as time goes on so that's what happens
in cosmology so you have this
plasma right all the electrons are
freely moving they have
electrons and you have protons protons
just kind of go along for the ride
because they're heavy the electrons and
the photons are what are doing most of
the work here
and so the dense region increases in
density the photons heat up and they
push back and in fact it's so pronounced
that the region that was over dense
pushes back and becomes under dense
now so it really is oscillating back and
forth exactly like a sound wave because
it is
a sound wave finally
effect number three those perturbations
get damped
because radiation
flows between them
in other words if i have some region
where it's contracting the density is
going up
heating up and it's pushing back so now
i have a difference in
temperature from this region to the
nearby region
which means there are more photons here
in the dense region but photons move at
the speed of light you know
it's true they keep bumping into
electrons so that's fine but if they're
not bumping into anything
they leak out of that region
the photons in some sense don't want to
gravitationally contract photons want to
be smoothly distributed
so as long as photons are important and
here they are
um the photons are going to damp out
these oscillations so when i said it's
like banging a gong
it really is because you know if you
bang the gong it vibrates back and forth
but the vibrations dampen out right you
know the photons want to restore
everything to a smooth configuration
and the final thing to keep in mind so
so what we actually get is this
in the real world here's our plot of
your small scales
large scales
again this means on the sky when we're
looking at it
here's delta t over t sorry making it
this way
uh here was our dumb naive prediction
that it was completely flat
the other thing to keep in mind is
larger
sized regions evolve more slowly
okay because everything here is evolving
you know pretty quickly
like relative to the speed of light you
know things are actually moving uh
comparable in because photons are moving
around and things like that
it's not at the speed of light but
that's that's a limiting factor
and so large regions you know
it just takes a long time for them to
oscillate and bounce back and oscillate
whereas a small region can go
boom very quickly right so in the small
scales what you
see are regions where they've oscillated
and damped
a lot whereas on large scales they've
barely moved and on intermediate scales
maybe they've oscillated and damped once
or twice or three times
okay so here you have you know
few or no oscillations really let's just
say few
oscillations here you have a
yeah let's say no oscillations down here
at the the very large scale
here you have a few
and here you have many oscillations
okay so given these three effects
that over dense regions contract they
heat up and they bounce and they
actually become rarefied
and then those oscillations are
damped what you would expect is instead
of this straight line
at very large scales you get the
straight line
because you just haven't had time to
evolve these these scales that you're
looking at the microwave background
are literally larger than the size of
the observable universe when the micro
background was
created okay the universe was big this
at early times
the observable universe at those early
times was much smaller than it is today
because we just haven't had time
to look at it they they haven't had time
to look at it so these large-scale
perturbations we see are
just whatever they were primordially
they haven't evolved
and as we go to smaller scales then you
get to a region where
you know if you look at the universe was
380
000 years old so once you look at
regions which are approximately 380
000 light years across
that's a region where you've had time to
contract
just barely right and then you haven't
even had time to bounce back yet
and that contraction increases the
contrast
increases the density perturbation
increases the temperature perturbation
so what you expect is something like
this that it goes up
okay but then it begins to relax it
bounces back so you expect that it
begins to go down again
and then what you're going to see is
it's going to oscillate back and forth
but those oscillations will be damped so
by the time you're down here
you're down at tiny little wiggles at
very very small scales because they've
oscillated and reached some equilibrium
and in between you get something that
looks like this
so you get a series of oscillations that
are damped and this is what you guess
this is what you so this is well we
guessed before the straight line this is
a much more sophisticated guess and you
can actually
calculate something like this and ask
whether it's right or wrong
then you go observe it right then you do
the experiment this is what we do we're
this is i'm not telling you a
historically accurate story but this is
a story that could be accurate if you
had slightly different thoughts um you
go observe it and you ask what you see
in the sky and you have a very very
specific
prediction compared to what you see this
is not
precisely what you see in the real
cosmic microwave background sky
it's almost what you see but it's not
quite let me show you i'm going to try
my best to use my drawing skills here to
show you what you actually see here's
what you actually see let me make it a
little bit thicker also just so
it shows up here's what you actually see
in the sky
okay what you're supposed to get from
this i hope that you know more or less
was accurate um the first peak is a
little bit higher
than you expected the second peak is a
little bit lower
than you expected the third peak is a
little bit higher
the fourth peak is a little bit lower
see i did it wrong already
i did it wrong it's supposed to be lower
what's supposed to be the case is that
the odd numbered peaks are higher
and the even numbered peaks are lower
so what we what we actually observe is
that odds
are boosted
and evens are suppressed
now remember i'm not telling you a
historically accurate story this is not
how
the story uh came to be but this is a
good way of thinking about it
if this is what you discovered uh
you'd be puzzled like you're literally
you
have a oscillating wave going back and
forth and it's being damped and you know
that
damping should be more or less uniform i
mean how in the world does it know
that odd oscillations and even numbered
oscillations are different
but if you think about it there is a
difference because remember
that first oscillation this big peak
right here that's when an over dense
region first collapsed
and we said that since it really is an
oscillation when it bounced that
this second peak so you know this is
let's pick us a certain
mode well what what should we say here
um
let's talk about regions that were
initially over dense they're also
underdense regions and they do the
complementary thing but this is a region
that is over dense
over and then the second peak
is when it's rarified okay in other
words it's under dense now
the a certain region will collapse
become overly dense and then it will
actually
empty out more than the average so it
goes to being
less dense than the average so there is
a difference between the odd-numbered
peaks and the even numbered peaks the
odd-numbered peaks are ones where an
initially over dense region
is moreover dense even-numbered peaks
are where initially over dense regions
are now under dense
okay so you ask yourself well what what
difference could that make you know i
mean
it's bouncing but it might strike you
well what if it
wasn't bouncing what if there was
something in the universe that
didn't bounce like that in other words
some kind of particle some kind of
matter that was contributing to the
energy density
uh that felt the force of gravity so it
could shrink
under the gravitational pull and it
could you know this first
thing gravitational instability happened
but this second thing where contractions
heat up and bounce
didn't happen in other words some
particle that was you know
electrically neutral right a particle
that did not interact with
photons some kind of matter that didn't
have electromagnetic interactions and
therefore it couldn't heat up but didn't
feel the pressure
if you had particles like that let's
call them dark matter
particles because they don't interact
with photons right
if you had dark matter particles what
would they do
well they would just contract they don't
bounce dark matter doesn't feel
pressure it's pressureless so ordinary
matter
contracts and then bounces and then
contracts again then bounces
whereas the dark matter just contracts
in that one region of space and that
gives a difference
to the odd-numbered peaks and the
even-numbered peaks the difference is
on the odd-numbered peaks the behavior
of the ordinary matter
is synchronized it's in phase with the
behavior of the dark matter
and in the even-numbered peaks they're
out of phase and the even-numbered peaks
the dark matter
is combating the in homogeneities in the
ordinary matter and in the odd-numbered
peaks they're working together
so it is a generic prediction of the
idea of dark matter
that you should see a difference in odd
numbered peaks and even numbered peaks
in the cosmic microwave background and
that is exactly what you really observe
in the data okay the reason why i'm
telling you this story in this
quixotic historically inaccurate way is
because
the first evidence we had for dark
matter was in things like clusters and
galaxies and stuff like that okay
and it very naturally led people to say
look you say
that there must be more matter in the
galaxy because the rotation curve or
something like that
there's more gravity there than we can
account for using ordinary matter so the
first thing they say is
probably there's more ordinary matter
than you think right
nowadays we know that can't be right
because of big bang nuclear synthesis
the number density of protons and
neutrons versus helium and hydrogen
would be different versus helium and
lithium and ethereum
would be different so we know that it's
not because we're missing
ordinary matter so the second thing they
say is well maybe gravity is wrong
you don't understand gravity uh and so
they invent theories like mond
modification of newtonian dynamics that
purport to explain the rotation curves
of spiral galaxies
now there's a lot more evidence for dark
matter than the rotation curves of
spiral galaxies there's gravitational
lensing
there's cluster dynamics there's the
growth of structure et cetera et cetera
but you could always try to wriggle
around all those things and find a way
to mess with gravity to duplicate them
the cosmic microwave background
is crystal clear evidence that
matter is not ordinary matter
protons neutrons and electrons is not
the only source of gravity
if it were you would see a uniform
dampening
of the oscillations in the microwave
background if you have another source of
gravity
that does not oscillate then you'd
expect to see this difference between
odd and even numbered peaks which is
exactly what you see
therefore the idea that there is no dark
matter in the universe is
wrong it has been ruled out by the data
it might be that gravity is modified
also
in addition to having dark matter
but dark matter certainly exists or as
certain as you can be in an experimental
science like cosmology
now people are still trying right so
jacob beckenstein years ago
i mean so i had to back up the problem
with
mond as a problem as a proposal for
modifying gravity was it wasn't really a
theory it was a phenomenological
relationship but it wasn't like
there was a lagrangian like you've all
watched all these videos you know that
if you want a new model in theoretical
physics
what you need is a lagrangian that you
can get equations of motion from
etc and mon never had a lagrangian so
beckenstein uh in fact there was a joke
there was something called bekenstein's
theorem
when the theorem was uh there can't be a
lagrangian vermont because jacob
beckenstein tried to find one and he
failed and he was very smart so
it's not possible to be done the problem
with that joke was that beckenstein had
not
tried to find a lagrangian and when
beckenstein heard about the joke he's
like i never tried to do that
and he tried and he succeeded because he
was very smart to jacob beckenstein
so he invented a theory called tensor
vector scalar gravity which was an
ungodly mess right it's like general
relativity plus a whole bunch of other
fields interacting in some very very
specific ways
and he was able to reproduce the
predictions for spiral galaxies that you
get from mond
so it was a sort of respectable version
of mond
and it made predictions for the cosmic
microwave background before we had
measured
the actual uh density perturbations and
they were wrong because of course they
were wrong cause there was no dark
matter in the model
but secretly there was dark matter
because you know there's a whole bunch
of other fields
in his theory right and these fields are
sort of mimicking up
the effects of modified gravity but they
are
fields that have their own energy
density
that propagate independently from
protons neutrons and electrons and that
act as a source of gravity
to anyone else we just say that's dark
matter that's what it is
so you may hear people claim oh i have a
theory of modified gravity that gets the
microwave background right
the question to ask them is how much
dark matter is in your
theory and by dark matter i mean not
just what you call dark matter what i
mean is
how many sources of energy density do
you have in your theory because without
them
you're never going to get this right
this is the reason not spiral galaxies
or gravitational lensing
this is the reason the microwave
background is the reason why we think
that what we're really seeing in
cosmology
is dark matter not to mention the fact
there's a dozen other tests that all
give the same
predictions so dark matter is real by
all by all means there could be
other things going on there could also
be modifications of gravity
but dark matter is really there so the
what we're left with is an inventory
for the universe where the universe
is uh five percent
sometimes people say four percent but i
think that gives a
an impression of precision that isn't
really there so
five percent is a rounder number
ordinary matter
that's what you need to fit
nucleosynthesis
and direct measurements and things like
that so by ordinary matter we need
protons neutrons electrons um you know i
guess there's radiation right the
radiation is something like 10 to the
minus 4
radiation today a tiny little sliver the
radiation the photons and neutrons
were photons and neutrinos were
crucially important in the early
universe they're less important today
25 roughly speaking of the energy
density universe
is dark matter and again we don't know
what it is
so it's perfectly you know good to
wonder what that is but it's some
particle
that doesn't interact with photons
doesn't feel the restoring pressure
doesn't form atoms it's not noticeable
in experiments yet
the problem is that that's too broad a
category it's too easy to come up with
theories of what dark matter could be
so we don't know exactly what it is yet
and then 70
dark energy we call it dark energy um
but it's almost certainly
the cosmological constant you know as
soon as we proposed
we found in 1998 that indeed the
universe is accelerating
that's why we have evidence for dark
energy and everyone said okay good the
cosmos constant is not zero
but you know most of us had thought
including me absolutely
that there were good naturalness
arguments
that if the cosmos constant was not huge
remember we we talked about
the cosmos constant problem in quantum
field theory in effective field theory
the cosmological constant should be huge
and it's not
so there's probably we said some
symmetry that sets it equal to zero
okay and we are wrong about that so
because we actually found the
cosmological constant people said look
we were wrong before
let's be cautious let's not assume that
it's the cosmological constant
so people including me made predictions
or built models for
dynamical theories of dark energy where
the dark energy was
almost constant over time but not quite
and those theories made predictions and
those predictions have so far turned out
wrong
that doesn't mean that they will
continue to turn out wrong just like you
know super symmetry or string theory or
whatever
sometimes the theories are just hiding
from you but
still as we talked about when we talked
about probability and statistics
um when you have a theory that you could
have discovered
evidence for and you didn't your
credence should go down
so i think that the chances that the
dark energy is really something
dynamical versus something absolutely
constant
or lower now than they were 20 years ago
or 22 years ago when we first found
the cosmodrome constant and i say that
this is what we call in a court of law
testimony against
interest because i would love it if the
dark energy were dynamical i would love
it if gravity were modified instead of
dark matter these are all ideas i spent
time thinking about but
when the data come in and i have to
change my credences that's what i try to
do
so anyway that's cosmology as we
understand it right now as i said
we've left out the very very earliest
times in the history of the universe you
know we have this plot
of scale factor versus time and we said
well what does it do
well the answer is a goes like t to the
one half
in the radiation dominated era then it
goes like t to the two thirds
in the matter dominated era so this is
rd md
and these days it has begun to go like
this
e to the ht in the vacuum dominated era
okay as far as we know well can he do
that forever
right vacuum energy doesn't decay away
it can
if there are noticeable
changes in the underlying fundamental
physics
so i recommend that you either go listen
to the podcast i did with katie mack or
buy her book she just had a book come
out about the future of the universe and
how it can end
where we talk about the future but we
also care about the past
you know if you extrapolate backwards
the simplest thing is
you hit zero at some time and you call
that the big bang
and we don't know what happened at the
big bang or we don't even know if it was
there
there's another possibility which is
that i'll make a different color
which is something called inflation
right inflation is basically the idea
that there was a
temporary period of dark energy in the
early universe
and in that case let's blow it up here
in that case there was this
e to the h t behavior with a much larger
value of h
so inflation looks like this
so inflation and then who knows what
happens before then dragons
there be dragons before that but
inflation is the idea that
there was this form of energy that
dominated the universe made it expand
exponentially and accelerate and then
that energy converted into radiation and
matter
and that's inflation and it's a whole
another complicated thing that you know
i've written a lot about and you can
read about i wrote about it from
eternity to here for example
but we don't know if it's true you know
i think that personally
50 chance that inflation is true
inflation is so good it's really
compelling theoretically for various
reasons
but it it raises new questions we don't
know the answer to you know like as as
you know from the entropy video
our big question about the early
universe is why was it low entropy
inflation by itself provides zero answer
to that question in fact it makes it
worse
the state of the universe you need to
start in to get inflation to go
is even lower entropy than the
conventional big bang model would have
you predict
so i even though i like inflation i
don't know that it's true and it's
certainly an extrapolation well beyond
the physics we understand
so i'm remaining agnostic about it but
it has become
the working hypothesis for the mo for
the majority of contemporary
cosmologists why
because it predicts this curve bang on
right this microwave background
prediction starting from scale-free or
almost scale-free remember
the exact thing that inflation predicts
is approximately
scale-free density perturbations and
that is exactly what we observe
in the cosmic microwave background so
that's a prediction that has been tested
the problem is it's a simple prediction
approximately scale-free density
perturbations you could imagine that
there are other
mechanisms that also produce those so we
don't know so
i like to remain agnostic about it but
you know progress is being made
data-driven progress gravitational waves
have now come in we're still measuring
the migrate background
we're still learning a lot about the
early universe i am optimistic that
this this mystery that we have why the
universe is made to the stuff it is
where it started from why it looks the
way it does
these are questions we're going to
answer maybe not in the next 10 years
maybe
some young person who is watching this
video will be inspired to think about
these and come up with the right answer
and then
i hope you remember what inspired you to
come up with those answers